outside of you and uh anybody on wu-tang
who is the greatest
rapper from a lyrics like a wordsmith
perspective in hip-hop history or some
of the greatest maybe some candidates
let's name a few
i mean you're going to have to start
with rock him
you know you're going to have to pick
kuji rap in there you know what i mean
so going back you're gonna you're gonna
have to pick up with those brothers
first you might have to even if you want
a get
technical you might have to start with
grandmaster cass
you know what i mean who you might not
you might not even heard of no you know
what i mean but you may have sung his
lyrics every time you sing sugar hill
rappers delight
because that's his that was there they
copied his they copied his and they made
it theirs
but point being made but
i i'll name a couple more i gotta put
knives in that category
you know we got a chess board in front
of us and one of the greatest chess
players
uh the youngest grandmaster you know
you know before i think uh
carlson
was uh
um bobby bobby fisher
all right so just use bobby fist as
american one of the greatest american
chess players of course susan pogar may
have tied his record as the youngest
grand master and she's the youngest
female grandmaster i think to date
but
he was a master at what 14
yeah something like that all right
so now
to me
i met nas when he was 15.
he was already a master lyricist it
takes about 10 years to become a master
lyricist so by the time the world heard
of wu-tang
most of us had 10 years of rapping in us
already
so that's why you you you met us at
mastery level the jizzer was already a
master
when nas was a master but joseph was 21.
the house was 15.
so nas is like the mozart of rap
yeah just bobby fischer because bobby
fischer just born some something in him
or maybe those early years just
because he's uh he's not just good at
the lyrics he's also he goes deep with
it yeah just like you so he's like
there's there's depth it's not just uh
like mastery of the the word smithing
it's just
the message you actually get
sent across the information yeah
into a small
phrase
right that's the whole thing of energy
how do we condense
all that energy into death
so that it can fuel that
and he's definitely one of those artists
emcees that does that
and he was doing it at 13 you know like
i said i'm thinking five years or four
or five years older than ours
so i was always feeling you know my
confidence of what i was doing but i was
like this kid is only 15.
i gotta step up my game yeah we got when
he turned 19 then we got automatic
you